there are a total of 60 people awaiting
execution the last one was carried out
back in 2006. Joshua paguera heard from
family members of victims who are upset
by this consideration Joshua
no the family is called this proposal by
the state infuriating disappointing and
traumatizing and they vowed to let
officials know how upset they are on
Tuesday
it's the slap in my face
it's a stab in my back
and for all the other family family
members of victims with a person on
death row you just spit in our face
Tyrann bolden's brother Michael died in
February of 2013. his brother's killer
Amar Harris is sitting on death row
awaiting his execution for killing
Michael and two others Michael's taxi
cab burst into flames on the Strip when
Harris shot the driver of another moving
vehicle that crashed into Michael it's
absolutely not fair
it it just makes you relive the whole
incident over again it just replays
every time something like this comes up
Jennifer tumbra also disagrees with the
state's proposal her 15 year old
daughter Alyssa was abducted sexually
assaulted and stabbed more than 80 times
while walking home from school in 2011.
her killer Javier regatti was sentenced
to death in 2017. he didn't value her
life he didn't care about her life why
should we value him
so I think he earned his punishment that
day I think that he deserves it the
Nevada Coalition against the death
penalty is applauding the board's
consideration Monique Norman sits on the
correlation's board her uncle was
murdered in 2017 in Las Vegas I can't
tell anyone how to feel or what to think
but I think
um
no matter what happens to this person
my loved one's still gone
now in a statement that we just received
to our Newsroom minutes ago Clark County
district attorney Steve Wolfson says
quote I have many concerns regarding
this agenda item recruiting whether all
Nevada laws were followed and I and my
fellow Nevada District Attorneys are
considering several options leading up
to the scheduled hearing next Tuesday
end quote reporting live in The Newsroom
Joshua peguero eight news now
Joshua thank you for that well the
Nevada Coalition against the death
penalty calls capital punishment costly
ineffective unfair and inhumane now they
add that it makes no sense carrying out
execution since the state is struggling
to obtain the drug that it that it uses
to administer death